how do I stay inspired and continue to
show up on my platform and aside from
letting the music speak for it how do I
continue to show up on the platform
meaning what content should you be
putting out or how do you stay inspired
to put out how do I stay inspired by not
beating yourself up when you're not
inspired you understand yeah that's the
part that [__] people up you'll have
plenty of inspirational days it's when
you know and you don't post you can't go
into it it's kind of like when you're
doing well with your health and you have
a bad day eating that's okay just start
picking it up the next day so if you're
not inspired to post for a week or a
month that's okay but I think people
beat themselves up for that but how do
you continue to make sure that your
audience is engaged or how do you the
audience May decline a little bit but
you can't force it like do you
understand yeah like yes your audience
May decline a little bit if you're
silent for three or four weeks by one
percent two percent but what's the
alternative you're gonna post [__] for
the sake of posting you're better off
protecting yourself than the algorithm